just fifty kilometers from the Russian
border
Finland's Jimena Kotka port is one of
the most important transshipment centers
for goods to and from Russia Tomi severs
as the port's sales and marketing
manager right now he's worried about the
crisis in Ukraine which is causing a
trade crisis with neighboring Russia
until recently one in every five
containers leaving this port was bound
for Russia
Tomi severs was counting on Russian
trade to keep growing was that the wrong
strategy no I think it's it's very big
opportunity to us and our main volumes
are still the finished exports but but
the growth what we are looking for it's
it's coming from the Russian business
ships from Germany dock at this key but
here - they're feeling the effects of
declining trade with Russia sales
director Coco Sorella says this is
partly due to EU sanctions Russian banks
are finding it hard to borrow money and
the rubles value has plummeted making
imported goods pricier decreased 20
percent in one year and the Russian
people they don't spend so money money
anymore only consumer goods these days
there are also fewer containers filled
with machinery being reloaded at Jimena
Kaka many Russian firms can no longer
afford to buy expensive Western
technology
but in recent years trading with Russia
has been a bit of a rollercoaster ride
the Finns have no choice but to remain
optimistic of course everything is
depending on a political situation in in
Russia Renault grain and and and after
that went that that will be settled down
of course situation will will come back
again another major source of income at
Amina kotka is shipping new vehicles to
Russia but the cars parked here seemed
to go on for miles they'll only be
shipped when buyers have been found for
them in Russia
Tommy severs doesn't have the exact
figures but he reckons that business has
fallen by 30 percent he just hopes that
Russia doesn't ban the import of Western
cars it is very very hot area and I
don't believe that it will it will
happen in at least in not in full force
they might have some restrictions but
but not in not not total stuff but he
and the city of Kaka can't rely on that
so together with a Regional Development
Agency
Tommy severs is scouting for new clients
in Brazil for instance Russia is
granting import licenses to Brazilian
food suppliers to compensate for the
loss of food imports from the EU and at
Jimena kotka they hope to profit from
the transport know when there are
sanctions against the European producers
for example in the daily goods and so
forth
Graciela might be one of the countries
to replace those volumes and naturally
David need to have those logistics
routes the first delegation from
press'll is coming here next Monday to
study these opportunities
Tommy severs will continue to monitor
the situation in Ukraine closely he
knows that should the crisis worsen
there will be tough times ahead at
Jimena Kaka
you